his son Raymond jr. was just 22 when he
was killed by the paramilitary group the
Ulster Volunteer Force it's now been 19
years since Raymond McCord buried his
eldest son at this graveyard in northern
Belfast I never heard of him being in
trouble yeah all right take him home so
I was a heart and smell the everybody
thanks about their own kids over 3,600
people were killed during the Northern
Ireland troubles what's unusual about
Raymond McCord's case is that those
thought to be responsible for the
killing are known to the police they
belong to the loyalists UVF paramilitary
group that still controls residential
areas in Belfast the man thought to have
ordered the killing mark hey Doc was
reportedly an informer for the British
police he tipped off the authorities
about planned bomb attacks and other
vital details McCord believes that's why
he has never been convicted for
Raymond's murder he's fought for years
to get haddock and others brought before
a court and has written a book about his
story he believes the police are simply
protecting their informers 19 years from
Raymond's murder we haven't had an
inquest the police keeps saying of what
what the tales are honest it's all gone
investigation 19 years yellow that's a
part of the cover-up
but he and his lawyer are not giving up
they are even appealing to Britain's
Supreme Court to try and get brexit
overturned they believe that with the UK
in the European Union there's more
pressure on the authorities to
investigate the crimes of the Northern
Ireland conflict what I have the perfect
real office what we believe is that if
there's a bracket then the next natural
step for the UK government edge to
withdraw from the European Convention
human rights there's already been some
discussion on a better UK Bill of Rights
so if that is the case then no we
wouldn't have that option of going to
the am the courts in Europe but McCord
and his lawyer have powerful opponents
many in northern islands parliament
voted for brexit and the Democratic
decision has been Tim as not for
individual mr. McCoy who hold up their
puny hand and triumphs what that we
should be pulling together to make a
huge success as it will be operated and
to embrace the opportunities mccord
fears that Breck said could further
deepen the divisions in Northern Ireland
the scars of the past are still very
evident here huge walls divide the
Catholic and Protestant areas McCord has
often received death threats because of
his outspoken criticism of the loyalist
paramilitaries and his refusal to let
the murder of his son rest
no problems are in the car I was to walk
up and down here and these people dlr
say they rode to see me from the
Shankill area there's a red possible day
lakardos the guys who's come down
looking for me McCord regularly meets
with relatives of other murder victims
from the Northern Ireland conflict
Kieran Fox's father was killed over 20
years ago he to spend years trying to
get the case brought to court but to no
avail once again the suspected murderer
was said to be a police informer the
father was 42 you need aid you this is
riemann said earlier he was shot for
being a Catholic saga face they keep us
the idea tins on stated just hold on
that state isn't made following Jewish
on Gary or bull shark her face my father
was 86 kids names a hairless wrong yeah
the big impact yeah
the police like these families have
continued to lie to them you know it's
not just up it's not about people turn
around and it's about it's just a
figment me and mace on since that sound
like a bit of all of as a gala mccord
believes the European Court of Human
Rights is his last hope of seeing his
sons murderers brought to justice now he
hopes brexit won't get in his way